- The only guy I was ever
attracted to is Justin Timberlake
and I don't know Justin Timberlake, so,
I've never had an opportunity.
- I know this guy a little bit,
we've known each other since high school.
- We go to the gym together,
so it'll be interesting gym talk.
- I literally just met him, like, what,
ten minutes ago, ten minutes ago.
- We'll get beers afterward.
(guy laughs nervously)
- I don't know how to feel.
I honestly don't know what to do
with my gum, that's the one thing.
- I feel like there's
been kind of a tens--
this is like the Mulder and Scully,
it's been building towards this moment.
- Be very conservative on the tongue.
- You swallowed your gum.
- I did swallow it.
- Your retainer's not in?
- My retainer is in.
- I don't know, I don't think
it's gonna be that crazy,
to be honest, but I'm the older one,
so maybe I've been around.
- He's, you know, a sweet
Midwest guy, so you know,
I'll take advantage of the situation.
- The pretending he's
a woman's probably not
gonna work too much,
he's got that full beard,
so that's gonna be fun.
So you wanna do like the tiptoes thing,
or you want me to kinda like?
- Go down.
- Come down?
(both laugh)
- This is good.
- I challenge you to find
the fake tooth in my mouth.
- I know where it is though. (laughs)
- We do it, we do it eyes
closed, open, how we doin' this?
- We just gonna approach.
- Yeah.
- Which way, you should go in this way.
- Tilt your head to the right.
- Wait, both of us?
- No!
- I want you to look deep into my eyes.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Mmm.
(laughs)
- There you go.
(both laugh)
- Mmmm.
- Oh, gr--
Ew.
- Go for it.
- Okay.
(laughs)
- Aah!
- The beard was, was interesting.
- So.
- Just a little scruffy.
- Wasn't so bad.
- I'm not gonna complain.
- You have softer lips than I.
- Oh well, you know, I'm
still young and tender.
(laughs)
- That got really weird.
(man laughs hard)
- I'm a good kisser.
- Okay.
- It's like a one step above a hug.
- You know, once you were into it,
it wasn't, like, weird,
it wasn't that different
than, you know, kissing anybody.
- He's just my buddy, gave
him a kiss, that's it.
- Yeah, I don't think it's a big deal,
I think we need to chill out.
- Yeah.
- If you were gonna kiss another guy.
- I wouldn't.
- If you were, if you
had to kiss another guy,
would you rather it be me again?
'Cause you know what you're getting?
Or would you want to kiss another dude?
- I mean, probably you again.
- I'd kiss someone else.
- You gotta work on--
- You know, that just kinda hurts.
- (laughs) I'm just saying,
you could be better.
- I mean, do you wanna go practice?